hello and welcome to the new world
review source for everything anime and
manga and today is a monumentous
occasion for i have finally caught up
with black clover and it is time to
discuss the second part of the spade
kingdom arc which has been potentially
the most enjoyable black clover story
thus far before that though i honestly
don't know where these videos are going
to go from here for black clover but if
you'd like to see more content on this
series then now is the time to make your
voice heard by liking the video and
subscribing to the new world review
which may very well result in regular
black clover content uploaded straight
into your youtube feed but picking up
right where we left off this chunk of
the arc takes us around middling stages
and to what is the beginning of an
action-packed climax without yami
william or a functional wizard king the
clover peeps are had a bit of a loss of
how to deal with this whole spade
kingdom issue but luckily a mysterious
character pops up
out of absolutely nowhere and steals the
entire series that character of course
being knocked so from time to time yes i
have found myself wondering why the
black balls did not have a vice captain
it did always seem a little bit strange
but i have to admit i kind of stopped
caring about that particular question
mark when it became clear that the magic
knight ranking system was
all over the place and a little bit
pointless which in a way
is pretty great because it allowed knox
to take me completely by surprise he is
a fantastic addition to the story for
ever so many reasons i mean firstly it's
hard to argue with the sleek cool design
and fascinating devil powers
as i suppose that really is the general
premise of black clover's entire
existence but placing narcs right here
and now
is such perfect timing to use him as a
bit of a multi-tool knox serves so many
technical purposes in the sock the first
of which is to provide insight into the
plans of the dark triad as well as
become the gateway to the spade kingdom
which is fantastic that saves us
a lot of screwing around and general
cringe plan dialogue emitting from
villains but narct also serves as a
mechanism into learning more about the
devils and it even introduces us
properly to our second
series stealing character but more
importantly nacht is also able to fill
the void of leadership left by
army and even the wizard king to be
honest because yeah i get it you're
there but you're
not doing anything the point in keeping
you alive still
remains to be seen knocked on the other
hand is pretty damn functional and quite
seamlessly integrated dodging questions
about where he's been prior to this by
both being on a mission and the fact
that he
hates the black bulls a bit awkward but
yeah i also very much enjoy that his
vice captaincy was decided
more or less arbitrarily it reminds me
of the sort of thing that isaac netro
would do in hunter hunter by making
paris and his vice german solely due to
the fact that he finds paristan annoying
although narc comes into the series
packed with one line as my favorite of
which was if you don't want to be judged
by the way you look then don't look like
that
which yeah obviously doesn't always work
depending on what we're talking about
but it is decent general life advice i
mean for example if you don't want
people to judge you as a slob
then don't look like one put in 20
minutes half an hour every day to make
sure you look decent and then
bam good life successful i like it
knocked also just has a ton of sass and
a very clear belief system which i'm not
sure i've quite gotten my head around
yet but i am very fascinated by him so i
suppose we'll just have to wait for his
inevitable tarbeta micro flashback to
get the full picture but yeah that works
for me they do also like tabata
continuing his trend of naming various
leader figures after light and dark this
time
knocked of course being the german word
for night but narct also brings some
pretty amazing developments with him
deciding to train astor to be the
ultimate weapon which of course brings
us to lead i am so glad that asta's
devil finally has the name but we were
blessed with far more than just that we
also have an entire backstory and some
sense of how devil culture operates
and well it's almost exactly the same as
human culture what a surprise were we
the monsters all along the answer is yes
but lieb is basically devil astor having
been born without magic and becoming
something of an outcast standing up in
the human realm but then still being an
outcast before he met
a certain elicitor a name that i'm not
entirely certain how to pronounce
and this is something that i did not
come anywhere near expecting but this
is astor's mother allegedly although i
should have known better the moment that
juno's heritage was revealed it should
have been a guaranteed deal that we
would see some of asta's heritage as
well because
their journey is a mirrored and that's
just how it is with that said i am still
incredibly curious to know why lisita
abandon asta that's a question we didn't
even come
close to answering in this flashback
actually but i'm sure we'll get around
to it
eventually because lieb does appear to
know a bit more about that matter it was
very touching to see lieb essentially
adopted though and i suppose it actually
makes the banasta brothers in this weird
trans-dimensional mother-sharing
devil-filled kind of way which is also
fantastic because this goes back to the
same idea that we were generally trying
to explore with the elves the concept of
putting race aside and just uniting
around common interests one example of a
common interest being
a generally peaceful existence i suppose
but we now have a supercharged
incarnation of that right now by forging
this bond between
man and devil which will now have to
work together to face these absurdly
escalating threats so yeah let's move on
to that
knocked gives us a lovely explanation of
the plan regarding the seven day advent
an idea that i really like because it
presents us with this nice
game style scenario where we will
inevitably have to deal with seven waves
of devils roaming this world eventually
culminating in one big bad
boss devil and yeah i get that the plan
is to stop this whole thing before that
happens but
well that feels unlikely oh when tarpita
does like the most
tarbeta thing i can think of here by the
way he takes the time to lay out this
complex and very legitimately intriguing
scenario but then when it comes time to
implement it it becomes a ah that was a
bit too
complicated let's let's just do it all
now sort of affair with morris of the
diamond kingdom acting as an accelerator
to
the plan and i really really just need
to emphasize tarpita
always does stuff like this he crafts an
intricate scenario or set of rules and
then almost immediately breaks them the
magic knight ranking system i mentioned
earlier is one example where the system
was put into place but then immediately
rendered meaningless because the ranks
weren't an accurate representation of
anything tangible by the spot of being a
captain same thing with the magic stages
as well we have what like 10 or 11
different stages set up and none of it
matters whatsoever because everyone is
pretty much
already sitting at the top and now here
we have this wonderful seven-day advent
system which also doesn't matter because
we're skipping that and we're just sort
of doing it all right now i mean that's
fine though i'm used to what black
clover is and it does result in exciting
character moments at the very least
and someone we have not yet spoken about
properly here would be yuno i'm loving
his newfound rage field determination
it's a very refreshing take on a
character who is usually capped out in
the realm of
apathetic magic genius and seeing you
know fail is the best thing that has
ever happened to this character because
as a result
i want to see him succeed this time i
legitimately want to i have a desire
whereas previously i've never really
been invested in any other uno fight
prior to this whole zenon affair because
it was always a given that he would just
win because that's you know when winning
is what he does but in this effort you
know is assisted by
language uh language but it does make
sense because they are both gold and
dornies and need to combine their golden
might for the sake of william
etc and so on and so forth but still i
was kind of hoping that the [ __ ]
language arc might have been the last we
saw of him meanwhile noel and select
noel company have been taken in by our
previous antagonist partry and friends
who had vanished without a trace after
the reincarnation arc but it is cool to
see them here because
they will slowly be needed also i
continue to just
love noel in general within this group
she has very much become the natural
leader and very much become another
aster
just slightly smarter but full of just
as much drive and ambition which is
great to see
we've got some big problems to tackle
going forward though one of which is
that power in black clover has long
since gone completely off the charts and
there is no longer really any way of
quantifying how much of a threat
any particular character is except to
keep saying that their power is on a
completely different level to that other
character's power which was already on a
completely different level in and of
itself which has already presented
itself in our first two devil folk both
of whom are very cool and intimidating
as hell by the way i love their designs
but it does get a bit tiring to
consistently blow through that power
ceiling like we already spent
what 30 chapters presenting the dark
triad as completely out of the league of
the cliff kingdom and now we
immediately already have another threat
to deal with that is completely out of
the league of the dark triad but it's
not necessarily these two initial devils
that worry me it's
the the what ain't more to come after
them because the deeper we go the
stronger the devils become so at every
new gate we're going to have to do the
same thing these new devils are on a
completely different level to the
previous devils who were on a completely
different level to the other devils who
were on like a
wow completely different level to the
other devils who were on a completely
different level to the dark triad who
were on a completely different level to
zagret who was on a completely different
level to lick who was on a completely
different level to the clover kingdom in
general
and so on and so forth it's a very
classic shonen trap that many authors
fall into and it's done as an easy way
to escalate the drama of the situation
which
it's working out pretty well here in all
fairness but it is certainly becoming
very hard to see this climax ending in
anything but a sort of ridiculous show
of unearned power from our protagonists
or via some sort of deus ex machina how
do we do both and we just throw mario
leona at them i am so glad she's back
and actually
inviting her to the party is by far the
best thing that knocked has done for
black clover and while there are all
sorts of other intriguing things
happening here and there it's difficult
to put any of that into perspective
at the moment because this is the limit
of what we have to work with from here
on out black clover is a weekly
experience and i'm sure that we have a
long
long way to go before this arc comes
anywhere near close to ending but i
would like to take this opportunity to
say that black clover to this point has
been a great journey i very much delayed
reading black clover because
well let's be honest it doesn't have the
greatest of impressions in the wider
anime manga fanbase i kept hearing about
how bad the anime was and just
consistent [ __ ] on the series itself
in general so naturally i put it off and
while i can't speak for the anime
because i still haven't seen
any of it such comments regarding the
manga are complete nonsense
in a way black clover is the perfect
example of a well-crafted modern shonen
series it's certainly not the greatest
that history has to offer but
also not everything needs to be in fact
when you think about it at any given
time
only one thing can actually be that so
what happens to everything else they are
rendered meaningless
definitely not my mantra whilst reading
black clover has always been to just sit
back and enjoy whatever it is that comes
my way which
i feel like has worked out pretty well
tarbata is an absolute genius with
crafting
implementing and exploring characters in
particular i can't even count the amount
of primary and secondary figures we've
been introduced to but i can say that i
do legitimately care for the large
majority of them because tarbeta has
found a way to make me do so and that is
not at all an easy thing to accomplish
and yes i do have criticisms like a lot
of criticism some of which are bigger
than others but another one would be
that the world is pretty poorly built i
really do wish we took some time to
thoroughly explore cultures and give
context to locations because for example
right now
pretty much the only thing i know about
the spade kingdom is that it's very cold
there so cold that it's snowing
currently that is its only unique
distinguishing characteristic and
the same for the others as well with the
heart kingdom all i know is that it's
more natural with the diamond kingdom
then i guess they like rocks and when it
comes to the clover kingdom our home
well it doesn't feel like anything but a
super standard cut and paste location
having said
all of that though does it even matter
well you can very easily say no
no it doesn't not everything needs to be
this encyclopedic masterpiece of world
building and the same can be said for i
guess every other criticism i've brought
up during the series because in the end
absolutely none of those things made me
want to drop black clover from the very
get-go i was on board with yelling boy's
quest to become the thing that i did not
and still do not truly understand but
there is a ton
of magic in black clover courtesy of
tarmeter's grimoire heavily heavily
underrated magic that people really
should just you know
shut up and experience because in the
end it is worth it so while the series
is unlikely to be remembered very well
if at all in manga history it will at
the very least be remembered by me for
providing just a ton of fun experiences
that's kind of it and that's all it ever
needs to be in order to keep me
satisfied so thank you all for
graciously coming on this journey with
me and i hope that each and every one of
you continue to enjoy black clover as
well what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more black
clover content then please do check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for very maybe
regular black clover goodness delivered
straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time